In this section,
you're going to go ahead and
replace those strings in your
return statements with templates.
In your templates directory, make eight
new files with the following names.
Replace the previous return statements
such that they now return render
templates for each of your
methods in final project.py.
But wait a second, if we design
our templates before connecting to
a database, Python will throw an error
message when we try to refer to
restaurants and menu items that
don't yet exist in our application.
To get around this problem, we can
temporarily make a fake database out of
dictionaries inside of our
final-project.py file.
I have made some dictionaries which
will serve as dummy variables for
one restaurant, a collection of
restaurants, one menu item, and
a collection of menu items.
The source code for these dictionaries
is available in the instructor notes.
Go ahead and leave hashtags in
the form action and href path,
since we are focusing more on the
structure of our pages in this step, and
not so much their functionality.
Now, when a user revisits
these links in a browser,
they should see something like this.
The functionality isn't going to be in
place just yet, but we've just created
another prototype that we can use
to present our progress thus far.
Your template should also return a
different message to the user if there's
an empty menu, or empty list of
restaurants, maybe something like this.
Try and see if you can accommodate for
this corner case in
your templates as well.